how's it going guys matt here sorry i
don't have my camera set up i'm at a new
place and don't really have that
arranged quite right today we're going
to look at the decorator pattern in
programming and to start out we're just
going to look at the wiki because i'm
not uh trying to reinvent the wheel here
this is a pretty well known pattern at
this point but i want to talk about its
usage and in general when you should be
using it and
basically what the the professionals say
on the topic so we want to be sure to
cover this and we're going to start
getting into other ones too like
flyweight and i'll talk about those
briefly but more later so with that
intro out of the way let's take a look
at what the decorator is for essentially
it is an interfacing idea you can see
here in this intent section it
ultimately has a component with an
operation this would be the interface
this top end one uh i think here anyway
but what we're seeing here is some
inheritance mainly this concrete
component now this is one that is
something you can instantiate this one
up here is an interface they don't
really make that clear in this diagram
but interface this one implements the
interface and we'll show that in code
later and then what you have is
decorators now decorators also
use this concrete one because they do it
in sort of a cascading like fashion of
adding stuff it's a way to add
components and a way to have an
interface where you can decide which
components you want to add to do
different things there's quite a few
examples here and a lot of additional
reading you can do on the subject if it
isn't clear to you after this video but
hopefully i can wrap that up rather
quickly for you here are the common use
cases as stated by the wiki
well basically it's when you kind of
want to add remove things on demand like
it's commonly used in ui applications
and if you're doing it in bulk you can
uh put a state design pattern also
behind it flyweight objects a lot of
times these components will be things
that are exactly the same and if you're
using multiple of them you want to make
them a flyweight but essentially it
means you only want one instantiation of
an object and everything else if they're
using the exact same object well type of
object you just reference it we'll talk
more about that later there are some
drawbacks like when you have
combinations of decorators things tend
to get pretty complicated after a while
but there are some other patterns that
you might implement to help solve these
so we'll get more into those later and
here they mention things like the
adapter visitor pattern one of the great
things about decorators is they're a
composition rather than a top-down
hierarchy we'll talk a little more about
that because that's kind of the main
problem they solve is getting rid of
that massive hierarchy and rather just
having an object that you can decorate
up as needed another pattern we're going
to talk about is the facade pattern
essentially it is pretty similar to the
decorator pattern sometimes well i guess
it depends how you use it but yeah it
says it can augment the facade pattern
so we'll we'll probably see that more
later we just want to talk about its
base usage here but just keep that in
mind for later
and being that there are drawbacks and
different things you're doing with your
code and stuff there are alternatives
you don't always want to use a decorator
that's true for any of these patterns
you don't always want to use them just
when they're appropriate and you can uh
instead of a decorator you could use the
adapter basically converts interfaces
we'll talk more about that later uh the
decorator specialty is dynamically
adding and removing responsibility
that way you can get exactly what you
want the facade sort of like the adapter
it just redoes the interface in a more
simplified way usually a lot of people
will do this when they're bringing in a
library to their main project because
they'll put a facade over it or a
decorator or an adapter depends what you
need all right let's stick with
decorator though
here is some uml class diagrams you can
kind of see the same thing here there's
the client that's the interface it talks
to and there is what they call the
concrete component concrete component is
the one that you decorate up and add to
the uh the interface instantiation so
we'll uh we'll do that in code and of
course we're gonna do c plus plus let's
go ahead and just dive right down to
their c plus plus and here they have a
dynamic decorator almost a deprecator oh
geez shape colored shape and a main and
then they have another one for a web
page and then a static decorator with
mix-in inheritance so they've got three
different examples here with the c plus
plus code all right let's go ahead and
run these and we'll walk through them
and explain it i could write my own code
i kind of want to do something for like
you know a game like a character and
gear them up with a decorator because
that tends to work pretty well it also
tends to work pretty well for custom
making items and magic items what
properties you want to have things like
that there's a lot of uses of decorators
and
that can be used in game type stuff too
but you know that's just one angle all
right well let's dive into some coding
shall we we're just gonna pop open
visual studio code and open up our
design patterns repo from github and
i've already added a few things i added
a decorator folder and in our design
patterns folder i've added to the cmake
a new ads subdirectory for the decorator
and of course this decorator also has a
cmake that currently just adds a main
and maybe we could have it add a few
other things too basically the main is
going to be our client end and
everything else is going to be kind of
like a header only library so let's just
grab some of this code and test some of
it out so here's a dynamic decorator
we'll just
grab from well
let's grab all of this everything but
the main and we're going to put this in
a header let's get their main as well
just this and of course we've got to
include shape so knows what we're
talking about and let's see if the cmake
auto populated with that new ad it did
not so let's put it here shape.h to make
sure it gets the code it should anyway
just with the main actually but
let's just make sure all right so let's
walk through this from top to bottom
okay so this is the interface right here
it's just plain old shape this uh
destructor is virtual equals default i'm
not sure if that's required but i'm
pretty sure you want to have that for
every interface in general with your
destructor on there
and we have a get name that returns a
string this is a and it is const so it's
not going to modify anything and it also
equals 0 which means for c plus plus it
is a purely interface class or pure
virtual as they call it this means this
object cannot be instantiated on its own
you can't make a shape object it just
won't allow you you'll have a compiler
error okay now that we got that out of
the way but we still have shape to work
with so we're going to make another
struct called circle and it's going to
inherit shape so it's uh implements
shape it essentially is implementing
shape we're going to add some new
functionality to circle called resize
and this just takes an effector and mix
or resizes a circle with this radius
factor essentially times is the current
radius by a factor it's an odd resize
it's more like a grow or i guess if you
give it a decimal on the factor it's
going to shrink this this function
doesn't make any sense but it's beyond
the point essentially they're adding new
functionality okay and we have the get
name function that we are overriding
and now this has actually implemented so
you can use it it returns a string a
circle with the radius of whatever the
radius is we now have a circle that we
could actually implement or instantiate
and you see they do that here they
implement a circle or instantiate a
circle and then they do something else
before we get to that let's let's dig
through more of this code so they make
another struct called a colored shape
and this one inherits from shape now
shape
is pure virtual right so that's good but
circle which you can see they're not
implementing here is not so they're once
again working with the interface class
on this colored shape and here's the
constructor you see they take a color
but they also take a shape boy how can
you take a shape if it's pure virtual no
one can no one can actually instantiate
a shape to give this color shape right
untrue because of the whole polymorphism
factor you can say you can make a circle
and say
that is the shape so you would pass in
something that implements shape here not
the actual shape and that's inheritance
uh doing its thing and then we just set
those accordingly and you can see in
colored shape we have an actual member
function called ash well it's a shape
pointer and since these are pointers two
shapes that's where these easily become
flyweights because you know the pointer
is not the actual object it's pointing
to the object so whatever one you're
filling out here if you're reusing
circle over and over and you want them
to be the same you could pass in that
same pointer but of course if you modify
one of them it's going to modify all of
them so that's going to get a little
tricky the shape is public so the thing
about shape here is you can uh you can
call all shapes functions but you won't
be able to call circle functions
necessarily so easily because
this there's no nothing in color shape
that implements the resize except for
this potentially being cast to a circle
so
that's basically it for this example you
can see they make a colored shape they
give it a reference to that circle which
is essentially a pointer to that circle
and they give it a string red and then
they just see out get name so let's see
if this actually runs correct i'm just
going to use the terminal here
and let's see what we're working with we
already have a build folder so we'll
keep working with that so let's open up
terminal and go c make we're at the top
level here of design patterns top level
repo c make source
of the top level one is where we are so
capital s dot now where do we want it to
build dash capital b and then we'll call
that just the build folder little
trailing slash there that should be
enough
now we can call make well let's let's
just look at the folder here we'll go
down the let's go into the build folder
let's go into the design patterns folder
and we can see everything here we're
going to look at decorator of course
so let's go into there and there's a
make file so we want to just call make
and that builds our actual executable
now if you're on your root directory
source the sources root directory which
is where we are now you can still call
make you just have to do this dash
capital c and give it the directory
build
was it design patterns should help you
if you hit tab and then deco reader
there we go so now i should run the make
file in that folder and there we go so
essentially you can do it either way
i've showed you both now
and now all we want to do is run it and
we can do it the same way
we can we don't necessarily need to do
all the change directory is the point so
we can just go like this i think called
this deco demo yeah and that's just how
it was specified in the cmake right
right here yeah that will demo okay and
that should be good to run it let's give
it a run and we just immediately get an
output a circle of radius 10 with color
red so that code works you can see where
the fall off is from colored shape
there's no way
to call or resize on the circle so how
do you fix that right let's just try it
here let's try a resize colored shape
dot
shape
dot oh the only option we have is get
name now since these are all structs and
everything's public it's a little weird
usually you have stuff hidden and you
make a cascade so this is very simple
example but you see here we have no
circle but what we could do and this is
where things get a little awkward but
it's a it's a hack maybe it'll give you
some ideas is you can dynamic cast so
the auto
um
we'll call circle here standard i think
it's dynamic cast into a circle but
essentially if this ends up being not
null you know that it's actually a
circle
if circle
so it's not if it's not null
then we can assume that we can use it as
a circle
and we would just have to call it like
this circle dot resize well we don't
want to see out the resize but we could
essentially call the resize circle
resize and we pass it whatever factor i
don't know we'll just put a 10 in there
but you can see that it's not happy with
this now is there a reason i think we
need a certain header let's go ahead and
look that up so if you're not sure you
can always just do a copy on that
keyword go back to the google wikipedia
whatever you want to do type in dynamic
cast c plus plus look for the
en.cpp reference or maybe you're in a
different language that's fine and just
let's just look at this dynamic cast and
see maybe why we wouldn't be using it
right so you do call dynamic cast new
type it should say somewhere here which
header it's from uh okay it's not from
any specific header apparently we don't
need the standard on it me doing this
whole standard thing is i'm assuming
it's from the standard library but it's
not now it doesn't know what circle is
we want to cast to a circle pointer i
believe let's take a look at their
example here oh the pointer goes
afterwards like so let's go ahead and
give it a run with uh this here command
or we just go into the directory and run
the deco demo and we see that it got the
radius got resized okay so there's the
example of casting to
uh work with that example a little more
so naturally you'd want all this casting
and things hidden behind your actual
classes would be the next step here so
you would want like for example in your
colored shape here you would want some
kind of thing that checks if it's a
circle or what you know it gets more
complicated so let's check these other
examples see if we got anything more
complicated let's look at this web page
example and let's grab all this code and
uh not the main and we'll go back into
visual studio add another file call it
webpage.h
oops i'm doing it at the wrong level i
hit escape let's go to the decorator new
file and decorator webpage.h paste all
that code in and let's look at their
main and put that in there examples are
a little different okay since we're
using unique on this webpage test looks
like we are going to need to include
memory pretty standard there just memory
and that should make this understand all
that stuff and we also need to of course
include webpage and that should
straighten up the rest of the errors all
right so let's look at this webpage
and consider a few things here and we'll
walk through it so if we start at this
top of this we once again see there is
an interface with a pure virtual display
function and a virtual destructor equals
default pretty standard there for our
interface and then we're going to
implement this web page as a basic web
page we're going to keep a string of
html as a member and we're going to
override the display to just say basic
web page and not doing anything with the
html so maybe we'll just throw that in
here
as like a extra
html
and we'll just leave it like that i want
to put the html actually in here it
should be blank by default so there's no
way to actually change it but you know
what's the point of having a member if
it doesn't do anything at all you know
but uh maybe it's further down all right
so we've instantiated it well there's a
basic web page interface you can grab so
we see that there's another one this one
is also a web page it's implementing web
page and this one's called web page
decorator and it's going to take a
unique pointer to a web page and you see
it's going to move that web page in here
now move basically takes over the memory
that says now i now control the web page
so if you pass it here this essentially
controls the web page and you'll see
down here that this has a unique web
page a unique pointer now you can have
pointers to these base classes just like
we could with we could have a pointer to
shape and that's uh you know unique
pointers still pointer you can have a
pointer to it but you can actually
instantiate a web page so this web page
they pass in it's not going to be the
interface they could pass in a basic web
page that'd be fine and you can see here
that we call the web pages display
method so it's going to call whichever
one you pass in so far our options
appear to be basic web page now let's
keep scrolling down let's see what else
they make they they have an
authenticated web page which inherits
from web page decorator so it's going to
have all of this stuff in the private
web page and you can see they have a
constructor here for authenticated web
page that once again does take a web
page you got to have some legal web page
in there but now you could put in basic
web page or web page decorator end to
there any any web page you want and it's
going to call what this uh web page
decorator constructor can essentially
set this uh this one here so it's going
to call this constructor use this
set the web page etc but now we got a
new method here that we haven't seen
before we got authenticate user method
and the display that we're once again
overwriting now this time when we
override display since that that's what
we're gonna get when we call this is
we're gonna we're gonna first
authenticate user which is weird that's
not what you want to do on display
because it's just going to say what
makes no sense but whatever this is for
sake for example but you see we call the
display from the web page decorator
which is going to call this one which is
essentially going to call the web pages
display so the only thing it's going to
do is it's now going to have this
authentication in front of it
essentially but still going to use the
display from the original
web page because this decorator has a
web page all right let's look at another
one here's authorized webpage once again
uses our web page decorator does the
same thing on the constructor it does
essentially the same thing but now it
says authorization done so this is where
things get interesting because you see
they use this move and this move
literally takes it over you can't be
both and authenticated and unauthorized
at the same time if you move it from one
to the other new things take over the
memory the authenticated page isn't
going to know what you're talking about
anymore alright so let's look at our
main and see if we can make sense of
what they're showing in the client in
first of all they make a page
just a standard you know web page this
is the interface the one that can't be
instantiated but they can if you
instantiate it as the basic web page
because that one
implements it just the c plus plus thing
of how you do interfaces more on that if
that's really confusing to people i can
i could make a video on that someday
it's not really design banners it's a c
plus plus thing but i don't think i've
ever talked about it on my channel
really too
directly it's mentioned all over the
place in random videos all right and
then we do something else so we have
this basic web page but now we say okay
well let's make my page now
an authenticated web page and let's move
in my current page because you can now
that's going to seem weird but
essentially it's going the move is going
to release well there's nothing to
release here because you're essentially
taking it over you're saying this unique
pointer it was pointing to a basic web
page well let's make it an authorized
web page and uh let's pass in what it
was before and we do that again once
it's
authenticated apparently and then we do
a display at the end so this final
display should only display this this
one here the authenticator should say
authentication done is what we should
essentially see so let's go ahead and
rebuild and hit play let's make sure
cmake has this webpage
dot h that way it knows when things
changes let's open up the terminal run
we don't need to run cmake again well
actually we probably i think it
automatically did since we added
something there let's just run the make
file here and see if that's good enough
it should be run the executable and
there we go we got authorization we got
authenticate
now i'm i didn't think of this would
happen because the only thing we're
doing here is we're doing this move a
move and then we're when we do this
final display on the authenticated
what's happening there why is it going
through and displaying ones from before
okay so if we look at the authorized
call the web page is decorated display
so this should be this web page oh i see
so this is pretty interesting we're
essentially getting a cascade of effects
and that's probably what they intend
here with this move things around
so when we call that final display we're
already authorized so it calls this
authorized user1 but it's also going to
call this display here let's look at our
terminal output again i thought we would
get this one first but i guess with the
way it is oh they're doing it backwards
so they're casting to the to this one
last okay so they're casting to the
authenticated last when we call this
final display we are an authenticated
web page so it should say this when we
call display and it should call whatever
we're decorating so we'll go back to
whatever we passed in well we passed in
an authorized web page so first it's
going to call this so we should get the
authenticated message and then it should
call this one here we should get the
authorized done message second which we
do
and then we should get the base of
whatever else moved in which was
essentially this decorator here which is
just going to call display on the web
page the basic html so yeah that seems
to be working correctly and you can see
how you could cascade those effects
that's a great example
and you can see how if you continually
move it in you continually stack
previous uh iterations and iterations
maybe a weird word but previous versions
of it
and thanks to the polymorphism that is
allowed here
and unique pointers smart because we're
not leaving old copies behind anywhere
we're just saying hey this is what it is
now add a little functionality on so
pretty cool example there there's one
more on the wikipedia this is a static
decorator with mix and inheritance and
let's just take a look at it we don't
need to code it up i don't think but
what you can see here basically is that
there is no pure virtual it just it just
goes straight to circle here they
declare a circle okay there's no shape
and then they declare a struct that is a
templated thing so they name this
colored shape and they have a type name
here template type name instruct and it
inherits from whatever type so whatever
type you to say that's what's going to
get all the stuff from so naturally they
would do circle in this example
and you can see that uh the get name
calls the type names get name so your
type name needs to have that function or
else this won't work and as you can see
they do have a get name that match
matches that signature
and the only other thing they hold is a
string color all right and here's the
use of that static mix in one
essentially they make a colored shape
they call the template a circle you have
their variable name a red circle this
colored shape requires a string and they
pass in the string red and they see out
its get name and they give it a resize
see they can get to this resize function
because of this templated type
so that's kind of interesting we showed
in the first example that you could
dynamically cast it and check it that
way but that's kind of janky that's hard
to it's hard to like tell the client to
do that you know and if you have it
buried in code it gets real confusing
with that kind of casting but sometimes
you got to do it so with this kind of
method you don't need to worry about
casting they just need to make sure they
pass in a valid struct that has a get
name function essentially since this is
uh taking care of that but
yeah that's another way to do your
decorative patterns and you can see how
you could add in well
more shapes you could add in these
structs kind of endlessly of whatever
you want to uh
have a have a different shape up but
yeah i think that's going to be it
there's plenty more examples out there
i'll try to leave a few links mainly i'm
just going to leave this wikipedia link
down below but there are a lot of
websites and other videos about this so
if you're still confused on it consider
checking them out but in the meantime
yeah just look at the code study it a
bit it'll make sense uh when you're
coming up with your own thing that needs
decorated see if you can do this sort of
thing 20 likes first day i'll stream
some code that's that's the deal you
know you know link down below in the
link tree thing yeah i guess that's it
for this video i'll push this code and
uh hope you guys enjoy it hopefully it
helps hopefully it hasn't been too long
i've definitely droned on a lot i feel
like but i think we covered it as
clearly as can be thanks for tuning in
i'll see you next time matt from
codetech tutorials over and out peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
circle hold refi resize come on speak
correctly if you wouldn't resize
his default radius here is 10
that's what's going to start out as
helicopter in the background okay so
that's all good well and good